this is what remains after a wave of
fire a wood on the outskirts of paradise
blackened by heat is now grave with ash
this was filmed by a man who claimed he
only just escaped his neighbor's didn't
for the people of paradise there is
almost nothing left 90% of the city is
gone local hospital staff saved patients
and equipment when the order came to
evacuate some like nurse Nicole jolly
nearly died doing so my car got
completely engulfed in flames the cab
filled up with smoke and my husband I
called him and I said I think I'm gonna
die I love you tell the kids I love him
and and he told me don't die run get out
of the car and run she did run and
survived but in the ruins bodies have
been found and it's feared there will be
more across Malibu many have lost so
much dozens of homes have gone devoured
by a fire that doesn't discriminate
between trailer homes or mansions Malibu
is where much of Hollywood calls home
Lady gaga told her Instagram followers
that she had been ordered to head to
safety some going up to a higher place
to take a look Will Smith also used
social media to show the view from his
home if you are any evacuation zone go
now what was unwelcome here was this
tweet from the US president putting the
blame on California itself there's no
reason for these massive deadly and
costly forest fires in California he
wrote except that forest management is
so poor
he did later offer condolences and
thanks to the firefighters but it's
years of drought ferocious winds and
rugged terrain that locals say make them
vulnerable fires do not respect politics
though and so I would beg the president
to pursue a major disaster declaration
and not make this a political incident
[Applause]
firefighters have without doubt saved
homes and lives and for now they have
the upper hand but dry conditions and
strong winds are forecast to return and
with them come a fresh warning katarina
vote oxy Sky News